♪♪♪
>>> THIS WEEK, DISNEY ANNOUNCED
THE CAST FOR THE LION KING LIVE
ACTION REMAKE, WHICH IS SET TO
STAR BEYONCE AND DONALD GLOVER.
HOWEVER, MANY OTHER PERFORMERS
AUDITIONED TO A PART OF THIS
EPIC FILM.
HERE ARE THOSE SCREEN TESTS.
>> LIN-MANUEL MIRANDA.
>> HAKUNA MATATA IN MY MEDULLA
OBLONGATA --
I ONLY GOT ONE SHOTA.
AND THEY KILLED MY FATHER.
>> I'M SORRY.
ARE YOU CRYING?
>> NICK OFFERMAN READ FOR HYENA.
>> MUFASA, MUFASA, MUFASA.
AND THEN I LAUGHED.
HA.
>> CUT.
>> ALL RIGHT, DIRTY B AND OFFSET
AS TIMON AND PUMBAA.
♪♪♪
CAN YOU FEEL THE LOVE TONIGHT
NUKE NUKE.
>> HAKUNA.
>> MATATA.
>>
>> KIT HARINGTON FOR SIMBA.
>> OH, I JUST CAN'T WAIT TO BE
KING OF THE NORTH.
SORRY.
JUST COMES OUT.
IF IT PLEASE YOU, I'D LIKE TO
TRY THE MONKEY.
>> LL COOL J READING FOR PUMBAA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WILL YOU SAY THE LINE, PLEASE?
>> HAKUNA PATOOTO.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OPRAH READING FOR RAFIKI --
>> TODAY'S GUEST, SIMBA!
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> -- READING FOR SIMBA.
>> THE CALM BEFORE THE STORM
RIGHT HERE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JOHN OLIVER READING FOR ZAZU --
>> A VERY BAD SIMBA.
WE ALL THOUGHT YOU WERE DEAD,
SIMBA.
DON'T DO THAT TO YOUR MOM,
AND NOW THIS --
>> STERLING K. BROWN, AND
KRISTEN SCHAAL READING FOR TIMON
AND PUMBAA.
>> WHEN I WAS A YOUNG WARTHOG I
THOUGHT OF CHANGING MY NAME.
>> OKAY.
>> WHAT'S IN A NAME?
>> YEAH.
>> I GOT DOWN HEARTED.
>> NO.
>> AND EVERY TIME THAT I FARTED.
>> FARTED?
OH, MY GOD.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> MARY J. BLIGE READING FOR
PUMBAA.
>> HEY MAMA.
HEY MAMA.
KENYA.
>> JAMES GORDON AS ZAZU.
>> SIMBA, EVERYBODY.
>> CELINE DION.
>> OKAY.
FOR THE CHILDREN --
♪♪♪